الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث نقلت رويترز عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلانها اسقاط احدى عشره مسيره اوكرانيه
قرب سيباس كما قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها اسقطت طائرتين مسيرتين اطلقتا في
اتجاه موسكو من جهتها قالت وزاره الداخليه
الاوكرانيه ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا واصيب
اخرون في قصف روسي استهدف احد احياء مدينه
ذا فورجيا جنوب شرقي البلاد
وابدا معك مازن عما اعلنته كيف من سقوط
قتلى وجرحى نتيجه قصف روسي بالمسيرات متى
في التفاصيل
نعم في الواقع ازدهار هي ليله اخرى من
الليالي التي يتم استخدام فيها المسيرات
والصواريخ في استهداف عدد كبير من المناطق
وان كانت الوتيره خلال الليله الماضيه لم
تبلغ الذروه التي كانت قد بلغتها خلال
الايام السابقه عمليا الذي حصل خلال
الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه لخصته
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه عندما تحدثت عن
اكثر من خمسين غاره جويه خلال تلك الساعات
بالاضافه الى اطلاق اربع صواريخ مجنحه
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه ما حصل عمليا
عند التاسعه مساء يوم امس كان هنالك
استهداف لمدينه زابولوجيا من خلال صاروخ
قالت الاداره العسكريه والمحليه في
المقاطعه بانه من طراز اسكندر وادى الى
مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه تسعه اخرين بجراح
وقد استهدف منطقه مدنيه وفق ما اعلنت
الاداره في تلك المنطقه
ايضا يمكن الحديث عن مجموعه من التطورات
من ضمنها ما اعلنته قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه بان 10 مسيرات حاولت خلال
الساعات الماضيه استهداف مجموعه من
المناطق من ضمنها العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اشارت القياده الاوكرانيه الى انها اسقطت
سبعا من هذه المسيرات بينما تمكنت مسيرات
اخرى من تنفيذ غارات احدها استهدف مستودعا
للنفض في مقاطعه ريفني وهي الى غرب البلاد
عمليا يمكن الحديث عن مجموعه من التطورات
الميدانيه بالاضافه الى ما يتعلق بالقصف
الصاروخي والمدفعي بالمسيرات على مستوى
كامل خط الجبهه وهو ما نشهده في مقاطعات
الشرقيه تحديدا ما بينس في محاوله للتقدم
تقوم بها القوات الروسيه على اكثر من محور
وفق بيان قياده الاركان الذي صدر صباح هذا
اليوم اشارت القوات الاوكرانيه الى انها
تمكنت منصدي هذه الهجمات س ان كانت في
كوبيانسك تحديدا في مقاطعه الخرك حيث
حاولت القوات الروسيه التقدم وكان قائد
القياده الاوكرانيه في تلك المنطقه اشاره
الى ان القوات الروسيه خصصت ثماني فرق
عسكريه لمحاوله التقدم من البلدات المحيطه
وصولا اليها ولكن بطبيعه الحال وفقه بيان
القياده فانها تمكنت من صد كل هذه
المحاولات كذلك الامر على مستوى كامل
مقاطعه وهنالك سجلت محاولات للتقدم
الاوكرانيه وفق ما تقول قياده الاركان في
في